game six against netball league right uh
isn't stockfish say that it's supposed
to be a draw so 0.00 does mean a draw
sometimes but other times it means since
the joke I always make it means the
stockfish is out for a smoke break
it's just it can you explain the joke
and can you explain 0.00 yes so when so
stockfish will show an evaluation
which determines whether the position is
equal slightly better for one side
slightly better for the other side or
completely winning
you can
0.00.2 minus 0.2 that's all within a
balance you can say okay black has a
little sprinkle of activity something
white has that but if it's zero zero
zero
it could be literally a dead drop
meaning theoretically just impossible to
win but oftentimes what that means is
the smoke break joke is sniper says no
there is so much complexity within the
position the combinations of different
moves that are acceptable and okay it
cannot evaluate correctly
wow so even the end games are tough for
stockfish which is why Magnus won that
game because there was practical value
remaining it wasn't a dead draw he
continued to ask questions over the
course of six or seven hours he would
sacrifice a pawn he would sacrifice
another Pawn to damage the structure
evaluation stayed the same
because a machine could stop him
but not young and that was one of my
favorite re that that game ruined my
whole day by the way it destroyed
because yeah I made so many plans that
day it completely ruined my day but it
was a very worthy recap you were just
all in you watched that whole game I
watched the whole game and the world
championship was a crazy time because I
wanted to be first with the recap video
but I also wanted to be best with the
recap video so I spent all the hours of
the games watching all the live
broadcasts and getting all the
information all the variations and
trying to put that into the recap it was
a lot of fun it was a huge adrenaline
done when it was all over so just for
people who don't know that's the most
recent World Championship
um so you had a I mean that was a draw
after draw after draw after draw yeah
and it was It was kind of boring in that
way or maybe
our draws
is there like non-boring Parts within
the draw to you when you were like just
studying it carefully for me yes
for the average viewer no
that's the truth especially when the
game itself is not that exciting when
Magnus plays a strange move on move nine
or ten that hasn't ever been played
and then Jan has to try to exploit it
and he fails and no attack builds up and
they Shuffle their pieces for three
hours my favorite thing is when the
commentators like I don't know why he
did that I wonder why he did that like
yeah when the commentators are confused
that's my as a as a person who's just a
spectator just like
uh that's that's interesting because
then you the most interesting part is
about listening to the commentators who
I guess themselves might be Grandmasters
uh all yeah they are trying to I guess
just like Nepal just like Magnus try to
figure out what's the idea here what are
you thinking that's cool that's that's
that's an interesting part of the game
but other than that
it's it seemed um
yeah I was sure this is just gonna keep
being a draw especially in that
situation so it's almost it seems almost
remarkable that his uh Magnus was able
to put pull out a win in game six and
after that
now at least Magnus said that that that
ends it because now that was gonna have
to take more risks and that opens it up
to Pure chest and then
um who was that uh Steve Prefontaine
said like whenever it's whenever there's
a race is down to like pure guts then
that's when I win it there was also a
conversation about eons
first half second half in any tournament
in the first half he's just brilliant on
fire you could even say he was out
playing Magnus but the entire
conversation before the match was young
slows down and at the first sign of a
loss or a setback
the match might fall apart and that was
the worst way to lose there was
literally no worse way and it just got
worse from there and there I mean it was
one move mistakes and
but he's back
Giannis won the candidates again he's
gonna play for the world championship